you dropped out of school  because all you wanted to do  was to learn how to make movies yeah  that seems to me the only way to go you  know i mean i film school was never an  option it just  it seemed to me to be  a waste of time and a waste of money you  know my my film education really came  from watching other movies you know um  and and  i think there's um  there's a scary mentality i think in  film schools my small sort of dealing  with them is is is something that's  really terrifying i walked into a film  class and it was about screenwriting and  this guy the first opening line was you  know if you're here to write terminator  2 just leave now and i thought well  that's terrible there could be a kid in  the corner there that wants to write  terminator 2. that's his vision that's  his movie that's what he likes let him  do it you know